-This is how you play the game.
How you play the game
is you take
two ping-pong balls, right,
and then you try to --
you stand on that side
and you try to throw it and
land it any of my cups of beer.
And if you land it in a cup,
I drink the beer in the cup.
-Oh, wonderful.
And if I'm very, very good,
we carry him out.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Alright, get ready.
I'm gonna be honest.
When I play this game,
I play for blood.
-Me too. Oh, me too. No pity.
-No kidding. No joking around.
Alright, you can go first.
Roots, a little music?
-Who's first?
-You go first.
Please, after you.
♪♪
Oh, yeah. Sorry. You go.
[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Come on, Betty!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-This is insane!
This is insane.
Gosh, I'm gonna lose.
♪♪
-♪ Get it ♪
-You need more?
♪♪
Oh.
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Are we good?
Alright, that's good.
♪♪
[ Laughs ] No, no, no.
We have to finish the game.
We have to --
Alright. Let's finish the game.
Alright. You go. You go.
♪♪
Alright, go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh!
I won!
-You won?
-Here's the deal.
I won by a --
-I hate that.
-[ Laughs ]
-But you know what?
I'll do a good sport.
I'll have this for you.
-Oh, good.
-Here's to Betty White,
the greatest person
in the world, everybody!
We are back with
the amazing Betty White.
That was very good, Roots.
Now, the last time
you were here,
we played a little beer pong.
Here's how it went.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ] No, no, no.
We have to finish the game.
So, in honor --
[ Cheers and applause ]
In honor of your return,
which is my first win,
we've officially upgrade the
"Late Night" beer pong setup.
Let's check this out.
Look at this.
The complete standings are here,
but then we have this
nice LED board up here.
Isn't that amazing?
[ Cheers and applause ]
There you are.
Now, I started my winning streak
after I beat you.
-Well, I hate it
when you say beat me
when you came out
a little ahead.
Let's put it that way.
-And I didn't cheat.
Alright, here we go.
This time,
this is all the rules.
And everyone backstage was like,
"You're gonna let Betty win,
right?"
And I was like, "No."
-Oh. In a word, no.
-No. In a word. Yeah.
Competition.
Healthy competition.
-Okay, you got it.
-Let's do this.
Alright, here we go.
Here are the rules.
We take turns. One shot each.
If the ball lands in your cup,
you chug the beer.
First one to land two wins.
-Now, remind me how we play.
-Okay, good.
You take those ping-pong balls
and just try to throw them into
these cups.
-Throw them in.
-Yep.
-Can I bounce them in?
-Sure.
-Well, sure I can.
-There you.
Oh!
-What if that was in here?
-Then you'd have to
drink your own beer.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Ridiculous.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Chuckles ]
Oh.
-We always love it
when you come on, Betty.
[ Laughs ]
-Okay, your turn.
-Now it's my turn. Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It didn't even bounce!
-It didn't even bounce.
-Oh.
-Yeah. Drink it up. Yeah.
-[ Indistinct ]
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
Oh, my gosh. I love having
you on. This is great.
Alright, here we go.
This is for the win.
♪♪
-Ha-ha.
-Oh, my gosh. "Ha-ha."
-Don't get distracted, Betty.
Don't get distracted.
-Oh.
-Don't get distracted.
-Go again. You get another shot.
-I get another shot?
-Yeah, two shots.
[ Audience groans ]
-Gosh! Whoo-hoo!
-Distraction! Distraction!
-Yeah! Distraction!
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ah!
That's it!
[ Indistinct ]
I'm good at this game now!
-Congratulations.
-Oh, I love you so much.
You're the greatest.
And I'm gonna have this beer,
okay?
I'm gonna do this
'cause I love you.
You have to get back up
to rehearsals.
-Yes. Aww.
-I love you so much.
Don't miss Betty White host
"Saturday Night Live"
this Saturday at 11:30
with musical guest Jay-Z.
I love you. Betty White!